One of my earliest memories
is seeing The Lion King
and being
absolutely traumatised
when Mufasa - spoiler alert -
gets killed by the stampede.
That had a massive
profound effect on me
and showed me how much
a 2D cinema screen
can make you feel so much.
We did a screening of
Get Out in 2017.
At the end of the film
there was this massive,
rapturous applause
in the cinema.
It made the hairs on the
back of your neck stand up.
That is such a special and unique thing
that only exists in cinemas.
I think that human beings
are supposed to go to cinema.
I think it's intrinsic
to who we are.
It's something about
coming together.
Be it around a fire or in
front of a cinema screen
is just fundamental
to what it means to be human.
In the very earliest
days of cinema
you would go to see films
in really quite strange spaces.
The archways under
railway stations
in markets, in shops,
often at fairgrounds.
So it was quite a
transient thing.
So in the 1920s
the numbers really
start to go up.
There's heating,
comfortable seats
You start to buy ice cream.
Suddenly, this is quite
a nice thing to go and do.
People would risk life
and limb to go and see films.
So you would have
air raid sirens going off
fire wardens kind of
announcing bombs coming
and people would still sit in the cinema.
I think stories
are one of the things
that makes us
fundamentally human.
And as a neuroscientist
I've always been
interested in
how people experience stories.
How do these stories
affect people
when they're in audiences?
We had people in the cinema
watching this film.
Then we also had people
in my lab at UCL
watching the film by themselves.
What we found is that
when you're watching
with an audience
there's much stronger emotional reactions
than when you're
watching it alone.
When Jasmine and Aladdin
kiss for the first time
that is the spike
in electrodermal activity
in the signal
and electrodermal activity
is the strongest indicator
of emotional engagement.
I went to a screening of
Singin’ in the Rain
and I remember
sitting, going into
that screening
feeling really quite miserable.
And the film came on.
And by halfway through
I just felt absolutely elevated
and so lifted out of myself.
And it's that feeling
and it's that moment
that I always come back to.
Most of the time when
you leave the cinema
I feel, you know
changed in a way, whether it's
challenged or whether
I feel empowered
or whether I feel
kind of like energised.
There's a feeling that it evokes.
You're scrolling
through your phone
you've got the radio,
you've got the TV.
You're constantly being
shouted at by different voices
and unless you can immerse
yourself in that one story
you're not going to be
transported in the way that
cinema intends to
transport you.
The lights go out,
my phone's off
and I'm just so focused on
what I'm watching.
We live in quite an
individualistic culture
and I think whenever
we can come together,
whether it's a music concert,
whether it's a boxing match
or whatever
there’s almost this
ability to move as one,
to think as one, to feel as one.
One of the great powers
of cinema
is that it's the means by
which we tell each other
about ourselves
and it's a means by which we
develop our empathy muscle
which is like crucial to becoming better people
and making the world
a better place.
I remember seeing
Black Panther
and just the energy in there.
You're in a room
full of strangers
but all of you are
going through
the exact same experience
at the same time.
And I think there’s a
kind of sacred bond there.
Cinemas haven't
always been
totally accessible to everyone.
And that's a really important thing for us
to think about in terms
of people's wellbeing.
Decades ago
cinemas were not necessarily
wheelchair accessible.
Now there are laws in place
that mean they certainly should be.
Covid really reminded us
of how much we
need each other
of how much we are
social animals
and of how it is different
watching a film on your own,
on your laptop
than going to the cinema and
watching it in darkness
surrounded by strangers
who are miraculously
experiencing the same
thing as you
at the same time.
I suppose that at some point
they might be superseded by
an even cooler way
to give us a story
3D holograms or something.
But the idea that we would
stop getting together
as audiences to watch
a story as a group
I can't see that
ever disappearing
as long as there are humans.
Cinema is the place where humans go
to be reminded of what
it is to be human.